the fast and furious movies are
unabashedly big
dumb and fun offering plenty of
escalating craziness for their fans
the fast saga has been so successful in
fact that it's inspired some imitators
here's a look at the mini knock-offs
rip-offs and clones produced throughout
the franchise's long run
the 2017 movie overdrive feels like a
fast and furious franchise entry
but it's just not quite right it's as if
the creative team behind
overdrive wrote all the basic elements
of the fast and furious franchise down
on little pieces of paper
shifted them around a table and then
made a movie out of whatever mad lib
like plot summary developed
screenwriters michael brandt and derek
haas who also penned the script for too
fast
too furious wrote this tale about the
world's most famous and respected car
thieves
andrew and garrett foster played by
scott eastwood and freddie thorpe
they're enlisted to steal a rare bugatti
from an auction in france
but they get caught by the owner a
french crime kingpin
who then makes them steal a ferrari from
his rival to even the score
there's a heist lots of car chases smug
heroes and daring escapes
but according to stephen dalton at the
hollywood reporter it's ultimately quote
witless and joyless and a formulaic
adolescent male button pusher
a french production shot primarily in
paris overdrive was released in eastern
europe before a quiet debut in the us in
the fall of 2017.
the film earned about 9.6 million
dollars outside of north america
and just 7 793
inside of it still the film couldn't
have been all bad
since eastwood landed among the actual
fast and furious cast
for one film at least what are you doing
here well
i told you i was gonna check in on here
from time to time to see how you were
doing
by the way not so hot you can tell that
this 2011
swedish film is a fast and furious clone
from the poster alone
it features a fast car and a sku
typeface and a guy who sort of looks
like paul walker
and then there's that title born to race
has a big number 2
in lieu of spelling out the word much
like furious 7
or too fast too furious except that born
to race
confusingly is not a sequel the plot is
reminiscent of that of a fast and
furious movie
except with much lower stakes and much
younger people
you don't know a damn thing about life
danny played by
joseph cross gets arrested for illegal
street racing and moves to a small
town to live with his ex-nascar driver
father and attend high school
where he dives into the legitimate world
of high school sanctioned
drag racing he can totally beat his
rival if he gets his father's help
why because like fast and furious born
to race
is all about family also like fast and
furious
born to race spawned a sequel born to
race
fast track replaces almost the entire
cast with new actors playing the same
roles
but this time the action largely happens
at the distinguished fast lane racing
academy
unlike fast and furious these movies
didn't set the box office aflame
born to race debuted on video in germany
in 2011 before hitting dvd
in the us in early 2012 while fast track
originated as a made for swedish tv
movie
bollywood films are massive spectacles
that hearken back to the classic movies
of the 1930s and 40s
but reflect storytelling and
presentation elements popular in indian
culture the fast and furious movies are
certainly massive undertakings
but they're nothing compared to 2004's
doom which puts an
india-produced bollywood style spin on
the saga
the fast and furious films have a little
bit of everything and so does doom
but more so specifically the addition of
multiple
well-populated intricately choreographed
and passionately sung
musical numbers the first of three doom
movies concerns police officer jai
squaring off with kabir the leader of a
motorcycle gang that also stages major
heists
jai gets a street racer named ali to
stop the gang
and that brings them right up close to
vehicular chases explosions
and scantily clad female race fans the
big difference between the fast and
furious and
doom franchises is that the former has a
wall-to-wall rap soundtrack and
cars and the latter has musical numbers
and motorbikes
with a name like fast track no limits
you just know that this movie is going
to be about rebellious young people who
break rules and drive expensive cars
impossibly fast
that's what they get in this 2008 movie
a german production that
enjoyed a theatrical release only in
that region and
china and for good reason you know you
throw a punch the same when you steer
curve
you put too much thought into it yeah
and you don't think at all that's my
edge
shot on location in berlin with a cast
of mostly north american actors
this fast and furious knockoff even
includes a walker in the cast
not paul but andrew no relation who
plays mike
a member of a group of car loving young
people who hang around a garage
dangerously in debt they get involved
with some hush-hush
high-intensity underground street races
which can either get them out of
financial trouble or
on the hook to the evil crime lord who
runs the show oddly
five years after the film hit theaters
in europe and asia
screenwriter lee goldberg took the movie
to the us
in the form of a self-published short
novel adaptation
in which the action takes place in
america instead of germany
the asylum is a small independent
us-based film production company that
makes all kinds of movies
action horror science fiction that share
a common thread
they're all thinly veiled obvious
knock-offs of popular high-profile
hollywood releases
the asylum sends its movies to home
video markets around the same time that
the films they're cribbing from are
tearing up the box office
seeking to both cash in on the craze
created by the competition
or scoring some cash and rental fees by
viewers who are fooled into thinking
they're paying for the real thing
among the asylum's numerous and most
self-evident mockbusters
the davinci treasure transmorphers and
200 miles per hour
a cheap clone of the fast and furious
franchise that hit dvd
in april 2011 right around the time fast
five arrived in theaters
it's a generic fast and furious kind of
movie and the plot is
as by the numbers as it can get when
cocksure street racer tom merchant
dies in competition after losing to an
evil drug dealer named case
his brother rick swears to avenge his
brother's death by getting into street
racing too
after beefing up his 80s model car with
the help of a cool female mechanic
and dialogue like this what are you
doing
you ruined the car where's the
aerodynamics it doesn't matter
south korea boasts a robust car culture
so it stands to reason that the country
would also produce its own localized
version of a fast and furious movie
that project is the 2019 film hit and
run squad
which mainly focuses on the law
enforcement aspect a national police
agency detective gets demoted to a rinky
dink task force
charged with busting hit and run drivers
a dreary assignment turns exciting when
she goes after an ex-formula one driver
who has sunk into a life terrorizing
city streets and leaving destruction in
his wake with his fast and flashy
driving
despite having all the elements of a
great action movie in place
the filmmakers reportedly somehow missed
the mark critic yoon mean sick of the
korea herald wrote
how do you make a story about cops race
car drivers and street racing with super
cars
this boring the 2013 action movie
getaway
looks like an american movie because
it's cast full of well-known american
actors
and it was theatrically released in the
u.s but it's actually set
and primarily shot in the eastern
european nation of bulgaria
which provided a nice backdrop for
what's ultimately a shameless fast and
the furious wannabe
ethan hawk in between academy
award-nominated performances in training
day
and boyhood stars as brett magna a
retired race car driver
who is in for the race of his life
against time
his wife has been kidnapped so he has to
grab a customized ultra-fast ford shelby
gt500 supercar
along with a sidekick known only as the
kid played by selena gomez
and do what the bad guy known only as
the voice
says which is mostly speed around do car
stunts and commit crimes
getaway was soundly and resoundingly
panned by critics
it earned a three percent rating on
rotten tomatoes
while london evening standard writer
charlotte o'sullivan called it
quote one of the worst films of the year
by a country mile
just do me one favor will you shut the
hell up
shut up one of the most obvious and
explicit rip-offs of a fast and furious
movie
is strit reserie or street racers a 2019
russian film
in fact it plays like a copy of an
off-brand fast and furious
it's so familiar and by the numbers step
on
a man just out of a stint in the russian
army returns home to find that his
father's mechanic business has been
taken over by docker
an organizer of illicit street racing
events steppen's dip into the criminal
underworld of fast cars and loose morals
is made all the more inevitable when he
falls in love with
katya docker's girlfriend despite its
overwhelming debt to its blockbuster
inspiration
russian film-goers didn't seem to mind
the negative fast and furious
comparisons made
inevitable by street racers for proof
look no further than the fact that it
was nominated in five categories in the
2009
mtv movie awards russia including best
fight
best kiss and best movie villain check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite action franchises are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]